Michelle Unseld the creator of beyond
good and evil has reignited speculation
that a long-awaited sequel is in
development at Ubisoft I'm tomorrow and
this is the GS news update you've been
waiting for for the last 13 years and so
posted this artwork on Instagram which
features a male engineer type character
with a pig sitting on his shoulder fans
of the first Beyond Good and Evil have
theorized that the pig could be a young
version of page the caretaker of
protagonist Jade it may also be an
entirely new character belonging to the
same sapient species as page as for the
mail some fans believe he could be
Jade's father the image is accompanied
by a caption that reads somewhere in
system for thanks Ubisoft for making
this possible it's unclear at the moment
what system for is a reference to the
last time Ubisoft officially showed
beyond good and evil to was in 2009 it
was believed that a project had been
canceled at e3 2016 however Ubisoft
chief executive Eve game or confirmed
beyond good and evil 2 is still alive
but didn't outright say it's an active
development or when we'd see it revealed
it's difficult to say Gilmore said
Michelle is working on it but he's doing
two games at the same time he's doing
wild at the same time it's coming along
but he has to spend more time on it so
we can see it faster more recently
speaking in an interview with gamespot
kima explained why Ubisoft isn't rushing
to show the game it's not only the
desires that are important it's can our
team come up with something that will be
a revolution you don't just want be
ongoing able to you want a fantastic
Beyond Good and Evil 2 and you don't
want us to bring it back as something
that isn't perfect that's a challenge
we're facing we have to come back with
something crazy and something that will
be great are you excited for the
possibility of a Beyond Good and Evil
sequel let me know in the comments below
or come and find me on Twitter I'm at
two more h and for all things beyond
good and evil make sure to keep it
gamespot
you